this video is sponsored by blinkist
we seem to be some part of the punchline
to a cruel joke
to consciously navigate this existence
with the desire for safety
triumph calmness and certainty hardwired
into us
all while being stricken to a chaotic
world fragile body
and mysterious fluctuating and different
universe
there are has been and will continue to
forever be things to worry about
as long as this dichotomy exists which
will likely be
as long as human is human there is no
shortage of reasons to worry and there
is no shortage of causes for assuming
those reasons
even when one does not have to at least
not yet
how absurd it would be to not at least
some of the time feel worried by the
absurdity of everything
but of course after a point worrying
about the future
and the unknown and the potential of
things going wrong
is nothing but a useless handicap we
mostly all know that over worrying can
sometimes be just as much of a problem
as not worrying at all
but this balance like most balances is
complex
how much concern for the future is
enough and how much is not
and how does one find out and reconcile
this balance without worsening the whole
problem
one philosophy in particular that
focuses a good portion of its attention
on addressing the problem of worry
is the philosophy of stoicism an
enduring
nearly universal school of philosophy
originally founded in ancient greece
and then further popularized in ancient
rome generally a key principle of
stoicism
is understanding that the only thing we
can truly control in life
is our internal domain our
interpretations
reactions and personal decisions and
everything else
the external reactions to our actions
other people
and the happenings of the world and
universe at large are things we cannot
this is worth noting because regarding
the issue of worrying
stoicism suggests that one should try to
maintain the following balance
an awareness that the things we are
worried about could and very likely
might happen
that life will contain moments of
tragedy and sharp turns
and that we should be prepared for these
moments both mentally and practically
in any way we can however equally
important is recognizing that many of
these sorts of catastrophic moments
can't be known nor controlled nor
predicted and thus
after a point worrying has none once one
has done everything that is rationally
and realistically preventative
they should work to revert their
attention back to the present leaving
all additional concern about the future
for the future awareness and rational
preparation have value to the future at
low cost to the present
but worrying about what one cannot know
nor control of the future
has no value to either and comes at the
cost of the present
following the stoic way of thinking to
potentially help counter this
unnecessary anxiety
and bring our attention and enjoyment
back to the present
we can remind ourselves that in the
future things might not be okay
but if they might not be then they are
now or at least better than the future
versions we are worried about
if we are worried that things will only
get worse then things are as good as
they'll ever be
right now and how foolish it would be to
ruin what might be okay now
out of concern of things potentially not
being so later
if one cannot know nor do anything
further to prevent it
and better yet if one is wrong about
what they're fearful of
then things will only get better and
there's even less reason to worry
moreover we tend to assume the worst we
tend to worry not only about things
going wrong
but the worst cases of things going
wrong paired with the sense that in the
face of such cases
we would be broken and ruined beyond
repair however
how often is this actually true stoic
philosopher seneca wrote
we are more often frightened than hurt
and we suffer more from imagination
than from reality epictetus similarly
wrote
man is not worried by real problems so
much is by his imagined anxieties about
real problems
in all likeliness there is someone
somewhere right now
living some version of a seemingly worst
case scenario for many of us
living with no phone computer tv and a
great many other things
unaware of this video and perhaps a huge
portion of the happenings of the world
and he or she is likely just as happy or
unhappy
as many of us right now we are adaptable
creatures
wired to adjust our worries to our
circumstances as well as our abilities
to remain okay
in the face of them and it is perhaps of
great use to consider and meditate on
this idea frequently and with confidence
that even if it went some version of
nearly worst case
we would likely still be some form of
okay the ingredients of your being that
have gotten you where you are
that have given you what you've
experienced will still remain
to paraphrase roman statesman and
philosopher cicero
while one still breathes one still has
hope
at least in some form in no way is this
to make light of the torment of enduring
and recovering from hardships in life
there is a spectrum of human horrors
some far worse and more trying than
others in some cases
it is entirely improbable to recover in
the true sense of the term
but even if this is true and one is
worried about these sorts of
unrecoverable things happening
then again they haven't happened yet in
truth how many things have we been
worried about in the past
that haven't crossed our minds since
individually and collectively
and what have we never worried about
before that we are unfathomably worried
about right now
how often has time erected or eroded our
worries in new but equal form
how often has the world ended but hasn't
how often has everything collapsed but
hasn't
how often has everything gone worst case
but hasn't
this does not mean that the latter two
never have nor don't
or that the former couldn't but
proportionally it's rarely worth the bet
french renaissance philosopher and
writer michel de montaigne
wrote my life has been full of terrible
misfortunes
most of which never happened arguably
many of us know all of this at least in
some form or another
in general we likely have or could
logically conclude that worrying about
what hasn't happened
or what we can't do anything about only
adds or creates unnecessary suffering
but yet most of us keep worrying
like with most difficult things there
are paradoxes and ironies found
in trying to implement these sorts of
simple seeming ideas of resolution
to try to resolve one's excessive
worrying requires one being worried
about their worrying at least to an
extent one can't use worry against worry
to eliminate
it and so realistically despite the
stoic ideas being so obvious
and perhaps simple in practice we'll
perhaps always remain
trapped in some amount of unnecessary
worry inextricably linked with the human
condition
and consequently perhaps our goal should
be reducing unnecessary worry
rather than removing it entirely and
perhaps by accepting this
that one will always feel unease and
that it is a natural part of the tragic
backstory of human life
paradoxically one might worry a little
less about worrying as a whole
if we shouldn't distress over what we
can't change or control
outside of ourselves perhaps at a point
we shouldn't distress
about what we can't control inside of
ourselves either
of course all we can do is try our best
and try our best to not worry about
whether or not our best resolves the
impossible
because in truth there is likely no
heroic ultimate defeat of worry
only small mini victories moment to
moment along the way
ultimately we are not special in our
sufferings nor in our overcoming of them
individually and collectively human
history is carved through trenches
we dip in and out of oscillating
hardships founded or
unfounded we are plagued by plagues and
hatred and conflict
and mortal fragility but if we are
fortunate enough to worry about
something that is potentially not
survivable happening to us
as opposed to trying to survive
something that already has it is perhaps
worth trying to be okay
while we still are
this video was sponsored by blinkist
with time's foot constantly on the gas
blinkist makes it easy to navigate and
learn from the overwhelming amount of
important non-fiction books more
efficiently and conveniently
by condensing complete books down into
overview summaries
blinkist provides key information ideas
and frameworks of books
in around 15 minutes if you're
interested in philosophy
blinkist has a great assortment
including the wisdom of life by arthur
schopenhauer
the way of zen by alan watts several
works of stoicism
and much more perhaps most usefully
blinkist can help you discover if a book
or
author is what you are looking for
without necessarily having to read the
full version first
additionally the overviews can provide
helpful refreshers in the books that you
have already read
all in all making blinkist a great
compliment for more comprehensive
learning habits as well
all book overviews can be read or
conveniently listened to within the
blinkist app
and for users who are interested in
delving into full versions of books
blinkist now also provides complete
purchasable audio books within the app
as well
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as twenty five percent off a
premium membership the seven day trial
is completely free and can be cancelled
at any time within the trial period
again if you're interested you can visit
blinkist.com
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you